to obtain or maintain Optimal Health Dr
Joel Wallach welcome to daily with Doc
and Becca
open the door oh wait wait wait wait
record I'm going to start recording
according to the cloud recording in
progress there you go
all right hello and welcome welcome
welcome everybody so excited to have you
here on daily with Doc so we have
several different ways to connect with
us if you are on YouTube or
rumble or Facebook make sure that you
look for the critical Health news pages
so on Facebook it's actually just
critical Health but on Rumble and
YouTube we have channels
under critical Health news there you'll
find all the information that the
critical Health news team offers as
resources for you and your communities
to be able to get information that is
empowering it is not limiting it is
giving you the opportunity to help
yourself and help those around you find
and write a better health Journey my
name is Becca dukes and as a Hostess of
this program it is my privilege and
honor to be able to provide to you
access to an amazing doctor I mean this
doctor
has years
of experience
in soil science
and comparative pathology
and then at nutrition and putting that
all together
in one package
I mean we're looking at a Bachelor of
Science in in agriculture we're like a
doctor of veterinary medicine three
post-doctorates and also and that's
post-doctorates and pathology I would
not want that job but he's done a very
good job at putting all of his research
together into what is now
a national treasure that is held in the
Smithsonian Institute the diseases of
exotic animals which is one of the most
utmost
reference books for those in veterinary
medicine well I don't know about you
but there's a lot of mammals that are
covered in vet veterinary medicine and I
myself I think I'm a mammal as well
I mean we're vertebrates we breathe
we've got skin
like a lot of different animals do so
when you think about it the things that
could negatively affect them are going
to negatively affect us as well and I
love how Dr Joel Wallach has put all
that information together and then went
on to write an additional 22 books that
share the information that we can
actually touch we can get a hold of and
we can utilize and put into action in
our own lives
we're gonna go deeper into a couple
subjects today and if you are on rumble
or YouTube or Facebook and you have a
question for Dr Wallach feel free to
join us here in the live Zoom room at
Daily with
doczoom.com this program is held Monday
through Friday from 12 to 12 50 Pacific
time again Monday through Friday so
welcome invite your friends and if you
don't want to join us live and you just
want to share this video with somebody
Click Share
and don't forget to subscribe also
so
we have so many people that are coming
in and joining us if you have a question
and you're here live with us make sure
that you raise that virtual hand I will
be calling on the hands as in the order
that they are received and we're going
to try to get to as many as possible and
if we don't get to you go to our website
daily with Doc Zoom daily with doc.com
and use that contact us this program is
sponsored by daily with Doc and yes
there is a store there we have all of
the recordings from our previous shows
there as well including previous shows
prior to what we now know as daily lit
doc that's all there and available to
you to be able to use for yourself and
to share with those that you love and
care about
and really focus on making a healthier
world so without further Ado it is my
privilege and honor to welcome to you
the one the only Dr Joel Wallach Dr
Wallach welcome to daily with Doc well
thank you so much Rebecca and thank you
team and uh it's a privilege to be with
you and your team and I can't thank
everybody enough we have lots to cover
today so I'm going to cover quickly here
so we can get to callers
and one of the questions I get all the
time is how do you prevent blood clots
how do you prevent Strokes what's going
on with those kinds of things
um what about all these
um bad oils and you know they're all
kind of related well I don't even like
to use the word oils because oils are
bad okay I mean heat oils you know for
frying or cooking or even you have salad
dressings they've been oxidized because
they've been sitting around for a couple
of months even in the refrigerator it
just slows the process down but they're
still oxidizing turn into trans fats
heterocyclomineesaquilomides all of
which cause inflammation your arteries
and they're the things that plug your
arteries not cholesterol
is trans fats okay and so you have to
stay away from them
so to do the right thing we at Young
Duty have created you know part of our
healthy brain and heart pack our efas
essential fatty acids these are
essential fatty acids that are made from
plants
okay and they will provide your body
with the essential fatty acids are
necessary for healthy cell walls uh
healthy blood flow healthy functioning
and various various things going on
inside every cell in the body okay as
efas
they're kind of a dark color Soft gel
capsules and then the EFA pluses are
omega-3s they're actually fish
omegas okay they come from fish okay
from fish livers and they do essentially
the same thing from a different
direction as the efas these are EFA
pluses okay but they do the same thing
but again from a different direction and
so this will help prevent reduce blood
clots and thrombosis and all that kind
of stuff keep the blood flowing properly
one of my favorite products for the
heart is Procardia FX oh my gosh you
read the back to this label it has so
many variations
omegas okay the good
um fatty acids in here and I take two of
those twice a day I take two of these
twice today okay little capsules okay
and they're called again Procardia FX
and then and more okay the
let's see here what's this one oh this
oh this is one of my favorites ultimate
daily classic now this will control
blood pressure control blood flow
through blocked arteries in the coronary
artery blockages and stuff like that and
we're talking about these products that
we just mentioned if AZ of a pluses
procardi effects ultimate daily classic
tablets will actually support people
even little kids who have asthma and
bronchitis and stuff like that it all
goes away because they're simple
nutritional deficiencies of the Omega-3s
okay you want to be using fried foods
and then taking the oils from the frying
pan and take those on your salads and
things yeah okay you will be in deep
trouble okay okay so you need to do the
right thing we have all these props here
now these are in addition to the 90
essential nutrients these are not well
I'm just going to take those no you need
to take the minimum of the 90 the
Healthy Start pack which is where we
started that's why it's a healthy start
back and then it became obvious that
most people were not doing everything
correctly so we came up with a healthy
brain and heart pack we could call it
the healthy brain and heart and liver
and kidney and muscle and digestive
system and the Brain pack but it was too
clumsy so we just thought the hell the
brain of heart pack
and all these nutrients I mean I take
them again just like you put oil in your
car you don't wait until the engine
burns up
okay you know just put dirt in your car
from Texas and hope there's oil on it
you don't just put dirt from Texas in
your car and hope there's brake fluid in
it you don't put dirt from Texas in your
car and hope there's transmission fluid
in it you get my drift here we have all
these different things you do for your
car most people take much better care of
their car than they take care of
themselves and that's why they die in
their 30s 40s 50s 60s 70s 80s when they
should be living to be 120 125 and so on
okay we know human beings can do it the
record in the industrialized world is
very recent 1997 a French woman by the
name of Jean Calment she died at age 122
years 164 days in France
and
of course we have the hunzas in the
Himalayan Mountains and their average
life expectancy is 120 and many live to
be 125 130 140 150 and that's because
they live in these little valleys
surrounded by volcanoes and they have to
plow in every day the volcanic ash which
are all these minerals into their
Gardens and their fields and then
um when electricity came out at three
o'clock in the afternoon Monday
September 4th 1882
oh there you go Hell's Kitchen you know
where I was going okay uh named after
that District in New York City where
every bad thing happens this goes
through thousands and thousands and
thousands of years of using wood and
coal as fuel and we put the wood ashes
and coal ashes into our Gardens which
are 95 to 90 minerals and two or three
percent carbon okay and Grandma used to
put those things in Wood ashes coal
ashes into our food as a as spices we
got the minerals that way also
but once they went to
the hydroelectric and built dams we
didn't even have bottom land anymore we
didn't have annual flooding anymore and
the farmers could plow in that silt from
the annual flooding back into the soil
and bottomland nobody would sell
bottomland because it's the most
fertiland because it was constantly
being re-fertilized by the by the silts
from the previous year okay well that
all went away
with hydroelectric and so the only way
you're going to add those 25 to 50
healthier years of your life is a
supplement even your salt we have the
seasoned salt from Australia we have the
Himalayan salt from the Himalayan
mountains
and I use that but my doctor says you
shouldn't use salt because it increase
your risk of blood pressure and that's
not true
that is absolutely not true every body
every cell every cell of every organ in
your body requires salt okay for doing
biochemical reactions in the body and so
forth
salt is one of the oldest
nutritional supplements on Earth
okay they realize thousands of years ago
when people would take sea salt
okay their glider would go away they
didn't know it was in the sea salt that
made the glider go away but they
realized and so everybody just started
using sea salt every day and glider
disappeared around the world
as the news got out hey you use sea salt
and glider goes away you use sea salt it
won't get goiter they didn't know what
was in it they just knew this they used
sea salt great things happen
and so we have to build on that and of
course we have our rebounder sports
drink with 100 nutrients in it 75
minerals and 25 vitamins amino acids and
so there's all kinds of ways to support
your body in its functions and exertions
and so forth and you can add 25 to 50
Healthcare very economically it's a lot
cheaper to spend a few bucks every day
on these things and it is to buy coffins
coffins
coffins I thought you said
talk to Wally well coffins
coffins that's where you put dead bodies
really
you are so funny
um so
so Dr well like
efas
all the things that you said that they
were doing that's like Nature's blood
cleaner
that's correct
it reduces the risk of blood clots to
almost zero
um we're talking about thrombosis in the
brain and the heart and the kidneys and
the aorta okay and then you know when
you're taking and remember these go
along with the 90 essential nutrients
and this one also has all the stuff that
helps build the walls of arteries
included so you don't get aneurysms and
things like that okay the pro cardi FX
same way with the rebound a rebound
helps you build walls of arteries they
don't get aneurysms and blowouts in your
arteries in your brain and your hearts
and your in your kidneys and so forth oh
I'm on dialysis for 10 years six days a
week I can't even pee I take people like
that and in two weeks time they're
pinned after 10 years and I've been they
cut their dialysis down from six days a
week down to three days a week and then
two more weeks they're totally off the
dialysis and you're back to a normal
life well when can I get off of all
these vitamins minerals never
when to get off of oxygen when you get
off of water
when you get off of ice cream never
well Dr Wallach I know that whenever
somebody is
facing Health crises it takes more to
get them out of that crisis and balanced
get the body
eating from The Good Foods
and not the bad foods and absorbing the
nutrition that is coming in so it's it
is possible and I am only saying this
because
I experienced that what I took in the
beginning
I don't have to take everything
now
because I was able to just give my body
what it needed at that time which was
extra
I mean it takes like whenever your car
is having issues takes a little extra
care to get it back on the road and then
you just maintain
right yeah well that's all in the book
there's two books again one is Hell's
Kitchen the other one is the Wallach
Revolution okay the long Revolution it's
a 75-year journey
that book represents a 75-year journey
and it covers not all of the 600
different diseases that I helped get rid
of but many of them the big ones if you
know like blood clots and strokes and
arthritis and diabetes and Alzheimer's
disease all of um kidney failure now all
those kind of things are in this book
okay the Wallach Revolution
75-year Journey
you forgot two really important ones Dr
Wallach cystic fibrosis and muscular
dystrophy okay yeah two thought to be
genetic birth defects okay yeah city of
roses musculosphere and also suddenly
death syndrome okay SIDS yeah those are
in there and those are all just simple
nutritional deficiencies
um
and uh it took from 1976 when I first
discovered it and the Yorkies Primary
Center Atlanta Georgia at Emory
University fired me when I said it
wasn't a genetic disease they fired me I
went back to school make a long story
short went back to school became a
physician and in 2011 I got the cloud
Schwartz award for the discovery in 1976
there you go for showing that that um
city cabrosis was not genetic and then
also we gave Jerry Lewis all the
information to show him that much juicy
was not genetic it was a civil
nutritional deficiencies and we showed
him so many kids and doctors reports and
he came and talked to these families and
the doctors and he was convinced that we
had found the cause of interesting cure
for musgravity he took it to the
muscularity association
in
2011 oh and they fired Jerry Lewis they
fired Jerry Lewis after he had raised
2.6 billion dollars for them they they
just barred him in a heartbeat because
he brought them the cause prevention and
cure of Masjid Shri
and then of course
the other one the third one uh is the
um
uh what do we got here oh seven of death
syndrome SIDS and that was the one that
really freaked me out because doctors
were saying oh see this caused my mother
is laying on the babies and suffocating
it's just hypertrophic cardiomapathy
heart disease the same thing that kills
young athletes in their teens okay in
20s and 30s it was killing these young
babies because those nutrients were not
in baby formulas so our great Attorney
John Seymour and I we sued the FDA eight
times in federal court one everyone for
that one we sort of much more than that
but those eight were on that one subject
we prevailed and force the Similac and
Enfamil and baby farmers of other brands
to put these nutrients particularly
these supplements some minerals in there
and you don't hear about sizzling
process anymore you don't hear about
muscles anymore you don't hear about
um uh let's see here the the sudden
image death syndrome anymore they all
went away because we put these nutrients
in the baby formulas and just for just
for a little bit of extra we came up
with our own baby formula baby food
formula okay kids tidy okay kids tiny
and one meal a day should be kids time
okay and kids are still breastfeeding
even if they're breastfeeding maybe the
mama can't absorb everything perfectly
you know so you want to have at least
one meal a day kids time even if they're
breastfeeding or if they're taking uh
Enfamil with all the vitamins and
minerals in it right they don't get them
all they just get to ones those eight
that we sued to the FDA for so
you do have to get them on everything
and it makes everybody's life easier
makes a family's life easier it makes
kids life easier and we save so many
lives and increase the quality of life
just by providing the body what it needs
the good lord gave us all the pathways
to do this we just have to provide the
raw materials and I'm so proud that all
this information is in the Smithsonian
Institute is a National Treasure and I
can't can't thank again
Jonathan Ward enough for being a
causative agent making all that happen
he he is an amazing individual Dr
Wallach and his passion for truth and
for those of you in the United States
the Constitution and making sure that
your constitutional rights stay intact
Jonathan emort is a warrior
for that and for making sure that the
FDA doesn't get out of line and that the
nutritional truth is also made available
so the fact that you and Jonathan have
joined arms in this fight I think is
absolute perfect fit Dr Wallach yeah
well thank you that was the beginning of
the
um coaches the health coaches our
relationship and so he says we gotta you
know do something here well I've been
trying to build an army Jonathan he says
well let's build an army with all this
information in it and so that's where
the health coaches came from
and the first health coach is one of my
very good friends Cheryl Morley
so
fabulous mentor
all the people Dr Wallach that have been
attracted to youngevity the company that
you started that you handed over to your
oldest son Steve who's now the CEO and
his wife Michelle who's the CEO and
doing a fantastic job Dr Wallach you've
removed yourself from the company you do
not receive a paycheck from them so that
you can sit here
share the information from your heart
from the research without it being a
paycheck coming to you yeah so and I
wanted to protect the company I want to
protect the Distributors and customers
so we removed all the peril
for using the Company products because I
you know I didn't show the company
into the
um
into the bad boys let's say it that way
oh
does require me to deal we know that
this
information is for informational
purposes only it is not meant to take
the place of your primary care physician
nor do our products treat diagnose or
cure any diseases but as empowered
individuals folks we have options
available and we are Beyond honored to
have one of the founding fathers of the
science of epigenetics that has proven
the transfer of disease is not what the
genetics theory has taught us for so
many years Dr Wally and I'm so thankful
for that that was like major Light Of
Hope for me because of all the things
that I was told that I had that were
genetic that I would just have to live
with and I'm going to give God all the
glory
I'm not afraid to say it praise God I
don't have any of those genetic diseases
anymore okay well this is one of those
things where saying that these diseases
were genetic was like saying that the
viral plagues
were bad
evil spirits
same principle they didn't know the
answer they so they just made up
something
well we're not making this up Dr Wallach
and the phone calls that I get the
emails that I get the messages that we
get on all the different channels
including the one here coming on YouTube
that was actually received yesterday
that I didn't get to
um they say the 90 essential nutrients
can get rid of many health problems this
needs to be taught in schools taught by
parents health in the future 99
nutrients one percent drugs or surgery
so I am in full agreement with that we
you know it's not that the nutrients get
rid of the health problems it's when the
body is given what it needs
because it's continually creating new
cells
if it's not getting what it needs to
create healthy cells it's not going to
have healthy cells that it's recreating
but it when you give it the nutrients
that it actually needs
then you're going beyond that just to
survive and into that thrive opportunity
for your own health
well said well said
yeah it's just I I mean my
to think where I was Dr Wallach and now
where I am and here I am with you
and we're helping so many people around
the world
I am still in awe
well let's go to hands that are up and
the first-hand Dr Wallach that we have
is an individual calling on an or tuning
in with an iPhone so iPhone
and it's showing up as iPhone 3 so
there's a few iPhones in our group today
go ahead and unmute yourself
so if you have your hand up and you're
on an iPhone there you go welcome to
daily with Doc how are you today how are
you I'm fine thank you and yourself
fabulous fabulous how may we help you oh
this has been so informative
um I have two questions
um about
um one is tinnitus
um I've had that for over 20 years and
I've been told that it's uncurable
um so I was wondering what what Dr
wallet thought about that and the second
one is focus
um I've been diagnosed with adult
attention deficit disorder about maybe
15 years ago and I was wondering what he
thought about that okay now the first
one
was tinnitus
yes rain in the years yeah yeah now do
you have any problems with changing your
voice or swallowing
no okay what about anything like the
dizziness or balance problems no okay
good
um have you had lots of receding gums
and dental problems yes yes
okay
all right yeah well you have
osteoporosis of the skull
tinnitus is created by the skull
squeezing
the um auditory branch of the eighth
cranial nerve and it causes ringing in
the ears sometimes it starts out in one
ear sometimes in both ears but
eventually get into both ears
it's very very common and very often
you'll also get something going on with
balance because the vestibular branch of
the H3 number gets squeezed at the same
time receding gums is part of
osteoporosis skull people don't think
about that you're Jawbone and your up
upper Dell arcade part of your main
skull are part of your skull okay so TMJ
September mandibular Joint part of the
skull mavascript process of the skull
the odds already have some osteoporosis
or arthritis somewhere else in the body
also you rarely just get it in the skull
you can be born with all this stuff it's
not a genetic thing or autoimmune thing
how much do you weigh
uh 170. okay and let's see here do you
have any diabetes or high blood pressure
no okay and let's see here hmm
do you have any memory issues
yes
okay I don't remember my childhood or
um yeah I I have very bad memory okay
have you ever done an MRI magnetic
resonance imaging of your skull or your
brain
no okay yeah because you could have
um
you know
um Alzheimer's disease okay you can also
have
um the other memory diseases ADD ADHD as
you have okay
um then there's another one called
FTD frontal temporal dementia which is
kind of an Alzheimer's disease where the
front part of your brain and the sides
of your brain are affected but the bad
part of your brain is still normal FTD
okay
and um
let's see do you have anything going on
with your digestion any belching burping
bloating irritable bowel syndrome
constipation diarrhea
no okay good all right so at 170 pounds
you need to get rid of all the bad foods
no fried foods no processed meats you
know like ham bacon bologna salami hot
dogs pepperoni jerky all that stuff's
got to go and then you absolutely
um no let's see here
oh
I'm hearing a lot of conversation in the
background there
go ahead Dr Wallach okay
um
then you need to get rid of all the
gluten no wheat nobody Ryan oats you
know Wheaton of iron oh so Arnold such
things as gluten-free oats the gluten in
oats is called gliadin but it's still
gluten and then absolutely no buckwheat
there's no gluten in buckwheat but
buckwheat has Faygo Pyrenees in it
f-a-g-o-pyrenes which are worse than
gluten no sugar of any kind and
absolutely no carbonated drinks even the
diet drinks got to go and carbonated
water got to go because they neutralize
stomach acids so you cannot absorb
nutrition uh primarily mineral nutrition
and cannot digest food then I want you
to 170 pounds to have two healthy pain
and heart pasture months two healthy
brain and heart fashion months full dose
everything twice a day I also want you
to have two bottles a month of our MSM
so you can take three at breakfast three
at lunch for your dinner time they're
going to support and promote
um
maintenance repair and function of the
brain the brain spent the brain stem
okay and including
um making white blood cells your immune
system
and and um so on uh platelets red blood
cells are all made in your bone marrow
then you need the collagen peptides to
scuba them with your morning dream scuba
their evening drink I also want you to
use a rebound you can have two rebound
sources a day we have the sticks we have
the we have the canisters we also have
the cans the cans do have carbonation in
them so I like to pop the tops on two
cans every day before bedtime put them
in the refrigerator so it'll be
flattened Off cast no bubbly in the
morning so I can have one with breakfast
and one with lunch or maybe within two
hours after lunch okay 100 nutrients and
a rebound other sports drinks in the
market only have one mineral
magnesium we have 75 minerals okay so
it's very very important as you go that
direction okay and then also
specifically essentially have ADD I also
want you to throw in our I-26 I-26 okay
this gives you 25 of your daily
requirement of cholesterol yeah
cholesterol is an essential nutrient
okay makes up 25 of your brain weight 25
percent of your spinal cord weight 95 of
testosterone and 95 of estrogen and if
you're giving up eggs and animal fats
and so forth because your doctor says so
well guess what you're in trouble that's
why you might have ADD because you you
gave up eggs or something like that or
gave a animal fast okay but anyway the
I-26
says it right on the label provides 25
of your daily requirement of cholesterol
because 25 of your brain weight is
cholesterol 25 spinal cords cholesterol
and if you're not getting enough
cholesterol you're going to get bad
things you're going to get uh
Alzheimer's disease you're going to get
FTD you're going to get
um multiple sclerosis you're going to
get let's see here
um gambury syndrome which is multiple
sclerosis of this spinal cord you're
going to get demolinization the white
matter goes away you get all the short
circuit you own the electric stuff
Parkinson's disease which is multiple
sclerosis with tremors okay and so all
these things are caused by a cholesterol
deficiency
okay and so you get
do everything correctly no frying no
burning okay stay away from
um
just
um bad fats and burnt fats and fried
fats and all these things go away you
know we take people with quote
Alzheimer's disease all the time gamma
rays syndrome all the time Ms all the
time Parkinson's all the time goes away
you got to give the body what it needs
and it goes away okay
so with that said is uh back to you
Becca
all right Dr Wallach so I have Fran that
wrote in and she's female 72 years old
118 pounds
she's wanting to know what are your
recommendations
for
here's one for you Dr Wallach
aspergillicus
fumigatus
that was found in her blood work I'm
sorry aspergillus
so it's yep aspergillus
f-u-m-i-g-a-t-u-s yeah well aspergillus
is a fungus
okay and so basically this is where the
colloidal silver comes in uh she needs a
90 essential nutrients you need to be
taking the healthy brain and heart pack
okay the other brand hard packed with
all the 90 essential nutrients and then
I want her also to have her colloidal
silver I take two droppers full under my
tongue 30 minutes for each meal and uh I
just hit a bottle here on the table but
I don't see it here right now there it
is okay there's hiding okay I put two
droppers full of this a little silver
under my tongue one under the left side
one on the right side when I wake up in
the morning I did say
um before at least I do it before dinner
time lunch time and
silver kills all bugs viruses fungus and
yeast and there's no alcohol in it
doesn't burn okay you can put on open
wounds and it is very very good about
killing things that cause infections and
messes you know so it's very very good
it's been around for thousands of years
it only disappeared from the big Market
in 19
um I think it was 1936 or 38 something
like that and penicillin came out
and doctors love penicillin so they went
to penicillin instead of the colloidal
silver because they got an office call
out of it
okay
also they get a prescription fee out of
it
um
okay and so that's why doctors went to
penicillin but penicillin only kills one
category
of bacteria
okay gram-positive bacteria
red clothes silver kills all bacteria
all viruses
all fungus engaged
so even the good stuff
what good stuff
well there is good bacteria
yeah well if you have good bacteria
what's going to happen is you have to
continue eating all the good foods and
re-implanting all the good bacteria all
the time okay you consume the good
bacteria all the time
well and my favorite way Dr Wallach to
get the good bacteria
I've got a couple of them
we have a pre-plus probiotic which are
little pixie sticks or pineapple orange
you just sprinkle them on your tongue
they dissolve instantly or I love mixing
them in my yogurt
and then I get the the pro pre and
probiotics plus whatever is in my
organic yogurt and just it's very
soothing for the tummy I absolutely love
it and I've had that question often Dr
Wallach well if it's killing off the bad
bacteria how does it know what's a good
bacteria and what does it do to the good
bacteria and there you have the answer
folks you've got to continually give
your body what it needs to be able to
have all that good stuff
staying in the body well
so thank you so much for answering that
question and we have a question coming
from Chris out on in the YouTube world
and Chris is 29 years old no health
problems wants to know is it's okay to
take 70 pills a day every day
well I take 70 fills twice a day plus to
heal the brain and heart pack twice a
day I also take two doses of of
um rebound today so I'm getting 100
nutrients I was saying four times a day
but I actually am getting
the 90th Century nutrients six times a
day
what's your 84 Dr Wallach Chris is only
29.
he wants to Chris wants to be 84 he's
got to do it I've been doing this since
I was nine years old
well I got a late start but I'm so glad
I started that's for sure
and then Stevie has a question in
regards to fatty lymphomas so what is a
fatty lymphoma
is it lipoma or lipoma yes
I forgot to go to school for that
lipoma
yeah I'll say benign batty lump or tumor
it could be the size of a pea it could
be the size of a basketball okay it's
just fatty tissue the accumulates in
places where there's irritation going on
and your body is trying to protect
itself by putting these these
um
fatty molecules in there to try and
surround the bad guys which are causing
inflammation and pain and so forth so
that's what a fatty lipoma is and
usually 99.99 of the time is benign and
most of the time the occur in locations
that don't cause any problem but if it's
going to be found inside of a coronary
artery you know in the heart someplace
it might be causing a problem okay so
location location
is something that's important to find
out here okay
so what are things that we would want to
avoid
that would cause the lipoma and then
what would we do to continually give our
body what it needs if there's already
been evidence of having these fatty
lipomas okay no fried foods no processed
Meats no oils no glutens no wheat no
burnt rhinos no sugar no carbonator
drinks you ever hear that before
I think that's called the the bad foods
from your good bad foods list which
folks you can find on daily withdoc.com
right there in the menu options it is Dr
wallach's 10 get bad foods list so feel
free to go there to our website and grab
that good foods bad foods list and print
it out so that you can have it to or or
hey if you're on your phone you can save
it
to your phone so you can reference it
whenever you're thinking about what
should I eat well there's a whole list
of good food people you love you want to
save them get them you know
knowledgeable also
yep absolutely absolutely when you go
grocery shopping Dr Wallach I just focus
on the things that are on the Good Foods
list
and as long as I'm focused on the things
that are on the Good Foods list I don't
have to worry about the things that are
on the bad foods list and it's it's no
big deal
it's there's so many things that we can
eat that are healthy for us good for us
that are not going to cause long-term
negative effects later
there you go
there we go
um and then we have another question Dr
Wallach
shoot where did it go okay so my
daughter is 38 years old
and she's having heavy periods that last
for 14 days
she takes many many of the youngevity
products she eats healthy organic meals
stays away from gluten she has super
allergies to cleaning products foam
products and more
so she's getting some
she's she's got a gut issue Dr well like
she's not digesting and she's got
allergies what would you recommend she's
114 pounds
38 years old and 5 foot
okay well again you got to start the
basics no bad foods no fried foods no
processed meat no oils no glutens no
wheat to burn rhinos no buckwheat
absolutely no sugar no carbonated drinks
you know the diet one's got to go and
carbonated water gotta go
and then at 114 pounds I wanted to have
one healthy branded hard Packer munching
take a half a dose or anything twice a
day she needs to take one bottle a month
of the MSM so you can take
um three breakfast three dinner time she
needs the
um collagen peptides take a scuba that
was a morning drink scoop that other
evening drink I want her to take two of
our ultimate enzymes to our ultimate
enzymes
with
um you know say five or ten minutes for
each meal a little bit of water okay
that's going to help her digest and by
getting rid of all the bad foods her gut
will heal but when you have
um you know things if you're eating all
the bad stuff you're going to get your
bowel syndrome you're going to get uh
those kinds of things okay because
celiac disease and so on diverticulitis
all that it's not genetic it's not an
aging thing it's not just something bad
that's happening to you it's because of
what you're eating okay what you're not
eating and again you know don't forget
all the good stuff
um there's efas the IFA of pluses okay
also the Royal cardia at FX and then
procore FX and then of course don't
forget the
um
you can see here the the stuff for
preventing blood clots the ultimate
daily classic tablets three of those
twice a day
and you do these things it's like
putting oil in your car it's like
putting coolant in your car it's like
putting
um transmission fluid in your car it's
like putting brake fluid in your car you
got to do these things before you have a
wreck
and then you won't have a wreck
there you go oh Dr Wallach we have
Anthony that is in the zoom room with us
and I think we could have a show on all
of the questions that he's asking here
um but there's one that I would like to
address so he's 32 years old Dr Wallach
he has never smoked in his life
and he has COPD
okay
now COPD trying to protective pulmonary
disease could be an instruction on the
tens cranial nerve osteoporosis of the
skull because there's a branch of that
10th Trail the earth goes to the lungs
and the diaphragm okay and so he needs
to clean up his diet through all the bad
foods and that let's see here
um he's weighs how much do we know
um let's go per 100 pounds okay then it
is one healthy brain and heart pack for
100 pounds of body weight it weighs 150
pounds I go with two Health abandoned
hard packs okay has 215 nutrients in it
and then also again I would have them
take the efas at him take the EFA pluses
I'd have them take the pro cardio FX I'd
have them take the ultimate daily
classic tablets I'd have them use our
rebound or sports drink with 100
nutrients in it
and then you can take our oxybody
okay he can take our oxybite take an
ounce of that or a half ounce start up
with a half ounce of breakfast or when
he wakes up in the morning and half
ounce say a half hour before he goes to
bed at night okay
and uh anytime he's exercising another
half ounce boxy body and
um this is not difficult you give the
body what it needs before you have a
problem ah you don't get a problem
and so if when you wait until something
crashes and things are really in trouble
it takes a lot more
um which I say to solve the problem
and unfortunately sometimes when you're
starting to solve the problem with
yourself because the medical
prescriptions aren't working real well
you don't make it
you can die okay so it's essential that
you deal with these essential nutrients
prior to getting the problems and huh
yeah 100 000 miles here
life okay it's one of those things if
you put all in your car you get much
more mileage out of it than if you just
don't put anything in the car okay
are you saying prevention is better than
having to be reactive that's correct
and so it's one of those things
prevention
is worth a pound of cure that you've
heard that before and then of course I
Was A Boy Scout and boy scouts or motto
is be prepared this amount of the Boy
Scouts
and so that's how I got myself out of
trouble when I hit all my health
problems I started doing things
that nobody had told me to do when I was
a kid nobody told me and so I just
started doing things because I was I was
following what we were doing for our
animals they didn't have my problems and
I cured myself in two and a half days
after five years of getting worse and
worse and worse worse they're going to
institutionalize me in a a violent
mental hospital okay and it's kind of
funny within a couple months after I
healed myself I didn't say anything to
anybody my parents didn't say anything
about it we just kept quiet
and people are pointing to me and
Whispering because it was obvious to
everybody in the church in the schools
that I was different
that's because I was taking those
nutrients and it had healed me okay in
two and a half days after five years
getting worse and worse and worse and
worse so I was so bad they were going to
institutionalize me and it was
essentially a prison hospital
well I think most hospitals are Dr
Wallach but that was probably one of the
the worst case ones because it limits
what you can do period and then when
you're
kept in a room where you can't wander
freely that's even worse especially for
a child and I know that it still happens
but it is like Dr Wallach said it is
preventable
and
I know from being in the health coach
course
that essential fatty acids are essential
our bodies can't make them we have to
take them in
and
not only are they essential but when we
were looking at the four areas of Health
doctor while like we were looking at
soft tissue and the lungs and the Brain
essential fatty acid deficiencies were
the biggest cause of the conditions
that affected Health in a negative way
and so many people are like oh that's
just fish oil I eat fish
that you're not getting it
you're not getting it listen because
when you're eating fish folks and this
is kind of gross when you think about it
essential fatty acids come from the
liver of the fish are you eating the
liver
I don't
but I'll take my efas with no problem
it just yeah
well there is a hand up Dr Wallach that
I have seen come through our our
critical Health News Daily with Doc
phone team and that is Kathy and folks
we do have a phone team that is standing
by for you if you have never spoken to
anybody about youngevity about Dr
Wallach about the products that phone
team number is
855-949-3377 again that's for those who
have never spoken to anybody about
youngevity were not referred to this
program by anybody specific
we do have that call team we have the
store at Daily withdoc.com and again the
number
855-949-3377 so Kathy go ahead and
unmute if you would please
yes hi hello welcome to daily with Doc
how may we help you today yes I was
calling because
um I was on Zoom yesterday
conference call with you guys that was
um interested in knowing
um I know they said no no soda uh
carbureted beverage so what about juices
is it okay to drink juice
okay we have to appreciate the juices
are full of sugar the amount of vitamins
and minerals in them is highly variable
depending on where the orange or the
grapes or the apples are grown
okay and so this is why we came out with
the rebound
it's all controlled okay and
um let's see I I'm trying to think
um I have a glass
not even a big glass but just a couple
ounces of wine with dinner every night I
do
um when it comes to juices
I'll use some lemon juice on my salads
I'll squeeze a wedge of lemon on my
salads kind of thing but I don't drink
when I was a kid I used to drink four
five six eight ounces of orange juice
there's four five six ounces of grape
juice it's all sugar sugar sugar
and the amount of mineral nutrition in
there is highly variable because
nutritional minerals do not occur in a
uniform blanket around the touch of the
earth plants only need three
we need 60. okay plants do not make
minerals nutritional minerals only occur
in veins like gold and silver and so
anyway you're going to get all the
nutrition is to supplement with
everything and of course if you want
something a juice or energy or wake up
in the morning use the rebound with 100
nutrients in it 75 minerals and 25
vitamins amino acids juice is primarily
sugar you might get some vitamin C we do
have a chewable vitamin C even little
kids like
that's fine because I um also
I like tea so honey okay
honey is that okay to put it on tea
okay well again a couple of drops of
Honey a day might be okay if you're
taking everything else if you're taking
all 90 essential nutrients
two drops of honey in your tea might be
fine but if you're taking two drops in
your of honey and your tea four times a
day and you're not taking vitamins and
minerals
that will eventually get to you okay and
so in a negative way and so you just
can't Blanche say oh Honey's good go for
it no it's not that simple okay you have
to be very restrictive and uh I I like
peppermint tea okay Peppermint's a great
herb kind of a disinfectant thing
um I like uh our triple treat chocolate
okay
um and so that's kind of where I go as
opposed to using honey uh we don't use
honey I we use a triple treat chocolate
and we use peppermint tea okay I hope
that helps out is that um is that a uh
like a chocolate a chocolate bar well
it's not a bar it's a flat it's kind of
the size of a uh checker
okay there's squares
okay so I can put that in my tea
I heard all or nothing here I will be
ordering soon okay
yes Kathy I have put I have put our
triple treat we also have one that's a
mint
and I have put them in hot water and
drank them kind of like a hot chocolate
you can add them to your tea as well so
there's a lot of things that you can do
um that that keep you away from the
refined
sugar
that's good because I like hot chocolate
so that'll be cool for me and tea would
be good too
I'm all right okay and one of our
certified holistic health coaches will
be getting back with you as well
okay thank you very much you get my
information bye-bye
thank you we've got it all right thank
you so much Dr Wallach and we are at the
end of our program
um we have so many questions we have
hands still up we've got questions in
and Dr Wallach real quick so Chris the
29 year old that wanted to know if it
was okay to take all these supplements
he's taken a lot of our products and his
mother is concerned that he's taking too
much
I wish my kids took
what he's taken
I'm just saying because he he's got the
whole
gamut going
and it's those nutrients that have been
found that when they're not there
disease occurs occurs
so Chris
I think it's Doc is it safe to say
that Chris is okay taking supplements
that are absorbable that are feeding his
body what it needs how old is Chris 20
something 29 29 he's old enough to make
his own decisions and I think he's a
really smart young man Dr Wallach well
he needs to give his mother maybe some
of our CDs or a book or something like
that and let her read and listen to some
of the stuff so she understands why he's
smart enough to take these nutrients I
mean I I learned it when I was nine okay
and so again I was a lot older than that
and
you have more people to help so I'm
gonna go ahead and let you go thank you
again Dr Wallach for joining us here on
daily with Doc during those 55 minutes
or so if I could get my co-hosts on
folks you are awesome you are smart
don't forget that you are also empowered
you have the ability to make choices
as to what you put in your environment
what you put in your mouth what you put
on your skin make wise choices life is
too short to go cheap just because it's
cheap and it says a name on something
that doesn't necessarily mean that what
is on the label is in the bottle
Choose Wisely I myself and I know many
of my co-hosts that I have with me on
today we went through that going cheap
because we heard it on the TV the doctor
said it was good for me it would help
take care of this and you take it and
you get nothing
well when you combine the synergistic
formulas that Dr Wallach and his team
have put into the youngevity products
you get the absorption and you get
results
we invite you to give us 90 days get
back with the person that share this
program with you if there's nobody to
think go to daily withdoc.com
if you would like to speak to somebody
and you have never spoken with anybody
before about what your body needs based
on the symptoms that you're currently
experiencing
we have certified holistic health
coaches that have been trained through
the Institute of holistic health in a
certified holistic health coach course
waiting to help you
you can go to 855 sorry call
855-949-3377 and one of my amazing
co-hosts that I have on with me are on
that call team and we're here to help if
you yourself have an interest in
learning this as well becoming a
certified holistic health coach whether
it's for your own purposes or to help
your communities this course is also
available to you you can get more
information about it at
coachwithbecca.com that's coachwith
becca.com or call our number and our
certified holistic health coaches can
share their experience with you as well
and help you get started so until next
time on behalf of myself Becca Dukes my
co-hosts Phyllis Anderson Maryland
spear Sherry Browning
Farhan Nasir and Roselyn Sanchez thank
you for joining us here on daily with
Doc
bye for now
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]